mon chéri j'ai une très grosse surprise
pour toi
je te le dis tu es fan d'une chanteuse
c'est la plus grande c'est énorme et ce
soir
Jordan
pour tes 104000 pour ton record elle est
là Mylène Farmer non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il faut choisir un bon coup je peux le
dire sans contrefaçon je suis un garçon
il pourra dormir je ne veux me Dédé dire
puisque sans contrefaçon je suis un
garçon
garçon tout seul dans mon cœur
card le riz de noir
[Musique]
à l'abri des regards je défie le hasard
franchement
[Musique]
pour vendredi pantalon je suis chez Manu
mais en plus il faut choisir un bon doux
je peux le dire sans contrefaçon je suis
un garçon mais pour un vampire je ne
veux pas me dire puisque sans
contrefaçon je suis un garçon
vous n'êtes pas du tout Mylène Farmer
c'est pareil elle est dans
elle est très jolie merci
[Applaudissements]
à Cherbourg
de Cherbourg à 11h on m'a dit tu viens à
12h j'étais en train pour venir te voir
[Applaudissements]
un amour ma chérie merci beaucoup
pour toi
et en fait je suis officielle alors je
fais plusieurs personnes
j'ai je fais 23 changements en deux
heures de sport
je vais te faire un cadeau tu vas nous
le faire en début d'émission tu vas nous
faire un petit spectacle avec plusieurs
semaines vendredi Merci à VOUS vendredi
tu peux le faire vendredi
d'accord merci à
[Applaudissements]